this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 39 sitting here with Echo Charlie
as they say
so
we're getting inundated with a lot of
information these days all the time and
it made me think about the fact that one
of the things one of the lessons that I
learned in the military was that the
first report was always wrong and this
I'm going to expand on that first report
is always wrong meaning you get a report
from the field
or you get you're in the field and you
get a report from one of your troops
and you've gotta
you've got to listen to what they say
clearly
but you also need to recognize that what
they're saying to you
is probably going to be wrong
why why is that well there's a bunch of
reasons number one
the perspective that they're giving you
is only their perspective so whatever
they're involved in whatever this report
that they're yelling about or screaming
about or giving you emotionally it's
just their perspective they can only see
something from their perspective at that
time what are the chances that when you
take a look at a problem at a situation
from one angle that you see the whole
thing what are the chances of that very
low not very low
so
they're not wrong but they're only
seeing a small part of whatever's
happening
second I already mentioned the word
emotional they're emotional about what's
ever happening they're scared they're
angry they're upset whatever so those
are
those are impacting the report that
they're giving you
also there's a decent chance that when
you mention proxy When you mention
perspective you also have to think about
their proximity to the problem which
means they're too close to it which is
also a distorted perspective because
when you're standing so close to
something you don't see it
all
so that what that leads you to learn in
the military is that when somebody tells
you something
I shouldn't say that their first report
is always wrong because that's too
strong the force first report
is not all the information you're going
to need
so what you learn to do is you learn to
take a step back you learn to detach you
learn to take information with a grain
of salt which is an expression I had to
we all know what it means but I didn't
really know where it came from and I
guess there's an ancient book
where they talk about taking an antidote
to a poison
and part of the antidote was to take the
antidote with a grain of salt
literal grain of salt which tells you
that probably whatever you're being told
whatever the poison probably isn't that
bad
so if you know you take this antidote
and you're including a grain of salt
it's probably not that big a deal that's
one interpretation of where it may have
come from and neither one of these are
confirmed the other one is that the word
Sal I don't know if I'm saying that
right in Latin Sal it it it means either
salt
so grain of salt or also wit as in like
witty but wit also means
good sense or good judgment so take this
hey man take this with some good
judgment yeah
so either one of those but we know what
grain assault means and that's something
that you learn
something that I learned
from the military is
when you get a report take with a grain
of salt
realize that there's emotions involved
realize that there's only one
perspective realize that there's
probably some proximity Distortion going
on
which is all important when it comes to
moving forward in the military but it
also applies to life so
what do we get today what do we get
today is we get inundated inundated all
the time with news we get inundated all
the time with social media we get
inundated with the story about covid the
story about politics this the reactions
that someone had all these things hit us
all the time 24 hours a day by the way
24 hours a day it's actually more than
24 hours a day think about it all the
news 24-hour cable news stations that
are all running 24 hours a day so you
take 24 and you multiply it times a
hundred it's 2400 hours a day and then
you talk about all the new sites you can
go to so it's more than 24 it's it's
thousands of hours a day of information
coming at you and what do we tend to do
is freaking freak out on each and every
single one of them oh my God
and so what you need to do is when you
get information out there in the world
whether it's from news whether it's from
social media whether it's from one of
your kids tells you something going on
what you need to do is learn to detach
take that information with a grain of
salt I'm not saying that that
information is wrong but it's probably
very likely not going to be the whole
picture so don't treat it as if it's the
whole picture don't treat it as if it's
gospel that's another thing we know
I don't want to make a decision
based on information
that I know there's going to be
additional information at least I'm not
going to make a big decision I might
make a little decision you tell me I
think there's enemy coming I might say
all right guys Lock and Load your
weapons yeah I'm not going to say get
online and attack no because I don't
even know what's happening
but I might say hey boys you know get
your gear on you I've said that many
times
hey get your gear on hey get the trucks
lined up that's a good one
that's a good one that's like a that's
like a good feeling I just got when I
said that I could tell you get the
trucks lined up which means you know
there's something coming down the pipe
we want to be a little bit you know
staged because you keep the you keep the
trucks in sort of uh what's it called
like a carport scenario you have a roof
right so it's not getting beat down from
the Sun a little protected from the
elements yeah but then it's okay get the
trucks lined up
and then this may you know guys start
doing the pre-maintenance checks so
we're getting ready to rock and roll
dude but do I say get in the trucks and
launch the trucks and start driving no
because we don't even know what's going
on yet
so you want to get the trucks lined up
okay
don't watch until you get gather more
information so I think this is I see a
lot of people a lot of time I mean God
especially if you go into social media
but the news does it all the time
everyone's freaking out about stuff
people are drastically
porpoising going up and down and up and
down emotionally over stuff
and it's crazy
none do that don't get crazy
detach
understand why people are saying what
they're saying listen to what they have
to say but please keep it in perspective
so what's an example of like when you
get some let's say everyday life right
you talk about the news cycle right so
what is an example like solely maybe if
some news report comes in about
something and then what you just
immediately go to social media repost it
and say disgraceful yeah or something
like that yeah exactly there you go and
then that then someone's gonna React to
what you just posted yes
yeah on both sides by the way that's not
disgraceful that's standing up for
himself I can't believe it and the other
side is I can't believe that that person
did that you know what I'm saying so
that's what everybody does 24 hours a
day and then you add to the fact that
everyone wants to get the big freaking
clicks and likes and retweets and all
that so that makes everyone insane yeah
so don't don't do that and yeah with the
news when things come out on the news
don't freak out about it listen to what
people have to say understand you're
you're fir you should see grain of salt
what is it skeptical skeptical that's
another synonym for the for the term
grain of scald is salt is skeptical look
at something to me okay yeah I get it
yeah echo's saying that you know uh
this guy's falling the sky is falling or
or Echoes saying that hey there everyone
at the Gym's got ringworm
like okay okay I'm sure some people have
it I don't think everyone has it
correct right yeah I don't think we
ought to shut this thing down oh no
first of all we don't need to shut it
down second of all not everyone has it a
couple people got ringworm got a little
ringworm don't die to ringworm that I
know of
um
people covered right now Omicron Omicron
right sure it's spreading very quickly
ah no okay cool spreading quickly
there's
a lot less Hospital cases from it you
know the first reports this is spreading
like mad the second report was like well
yeah it's spreading but it's also less
what is it less vicious than Delta
variant whatever hell yeah
so let's not freak out about things
let's listen
let's absorb do can you make a small
decision sure you can make a small
decision because someone's saying well
you might you might miss out yeah you
might be stuck
you know when they say oh there's a
fire
in California
what does that mean or there's a fire in
your neighborhood does that mean
abandoned ship and run away no it
doesn't mean that but does it mean hey
you better check your security system
you better make sure your your vehicle
has fuel in it to make sure if you got
to go you got to go I mean if you're
below half tank for sure we'd like to
keep it above three quarter tank but you
know what I'm saying yes sir I do
is your go bag good to go like just
normal things yeah
does it mean get crazy no
doesn't mean get crazy means you know
give the family the pro word for
prep level three
yes
Defcon 9. so there you go it's a very
important that oh
it is a very important thing to practice
it really truly is a very important
thing to practice with your team with
your family with your employees
being when someone it is a beautiful way
to
sort of practice this
is just saying Roger that to people when
somebody comes I'm freaking out about
you doing hey Roger that not not not
like blow it off but like hey Roger that
got it okay okay maybe ask a nice
question to make sure that you they
realize that you're listening to them
right but when people come up to me
freaking out about something I bet Roger
got it okay hey Roger that
where'd you see him or you know just
just engage but don't freak out yeah and
if you do this with your family if you
do this with your employees if you do
this with the news if you do this with
your life you're going to be better off
yeah you're not you're gonna be better
off you're gonna be more stable you're
gonna be more consistent you're gonna
have better perspective it sounds small
but it's a real it's a real thing and it
really truly is beneficial to your life
if you do this yeah
do you think sometimes like people's
immediate reaction like if they
if they jump too quickly right if they
launch too quickly
do you ever think that that is or it
becomes just like a habit for sure it
becomes a habit and it also becomes when
I launch I don't turn back yeah because
I already committed yeah I already said
disgrace and when someone says well he
was actually only you know that's a
taken out of context you don't you don't
go back and delete the Tweet because
then you look like an idiot right so it
said you just leave it and you say yeah
but even in the context
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground